hi everyone again
samir menon founder ceo of dexterity uh
also stanford computer science phd
happy to be back
thanks for your attention
it's uh going to be a bit of a
journey from us through
what we call
intelligent automation today and so
dexterity has been working on the next
generation
of intelligent machines in particular
intelligent robots that have the ability
to pick place pack orchestrate do a wide
variety of things in the logistics
industry
before i start a quick overview
of robotics i know some of you are going
to be familiar uh robots have been
around since the 1970s and the 1980s
the first
wave of robotics was pretty focused on
precision uh reliability precision in
the context of robots manufacturing
things like automobiles
a robot would be a mechanical tool you
program it to do a certain task there's
a lot of math that you need to work
through to get the robot to behave in
the way that you want a lot of that math
is contained in aspects of control
theory motion planning
long story short you can imagine a
manufacturing assembly line where
something comes along
the robot moves over it does a task like
welding a joint or drilling a hole or
painting something and robot moves out
of the way the next thing comes along
the robot does the task again
the first generation of robots were
really designed for precision
big heavy
um
kind of extremely precise and extremely
precise in the world of robotics means
like micron some levels of i don't know
40 50 some microns of precision
and
the tricky part with that
is when you have precision as the
foundation of the work that you are
doing
your precision
of course depends on
the the effectiveness of the machine
that you've built and the effectiveness
of the control system but your precision
is fundamentally constrained by the
precision in the environment
so if the environment shakes around
you could be super precise and unless
you can react to the changing
environment your precision is wasted
manufacturing as an industry was able to
invest
say i don't know fifty thousand dollars
to get a very precise robot and five
million dollars to build a very precise
environment and so with the five million
and fifty thousand dollars you can have
a functioning plant now you might
imagine that uh you know i buy fifty
thousand dollars of robot and i need to
buy five million dollars of conveyable
to make it work is not a very exciting
uh proposition for for many many
circumstances and it is feasible to to
take into production and do great things
in the real world if you are in
in
an environment where you're mass
producing something
the moment you step outside
manufacturing into the world of say
logistics and that's literally the first
step outside the precise world of uh of
machines you suddenly encounter a
scenario where everything's changing
there's still a big problem in terms of
the jobs to be done
and robots are fundamentally unable to
adapt to the variations in the
environment so
when dexterity started
my background was in
in control theory and simulation
we worked a lot on
robot dynamics algorithms we worked on
studying human motion trying to build
models that would allow us to transfer
human skills to robots
built some robots programmed some robots
enjoyed my time here during my phd and
we came out into the real world where it
was now incumbent upon us to solve
problems and when we think about solving
problems
uh there's a fundamental level of
abstraction that we operate under when
we are in
academia and that level of abstraction
kind of breaks because you're faced with
the real world and so what does the real
world look like and what is logistics
logistics uh for for many of us
is
something that that sits behind
you know a cloud of obscurity that uh
many of us are not particularly
um
interested in in penetrating and at
least i wasn't and uh
you know you you order something on
amazon you order something on any portal
magically a box shows up in your
footsteps
you walk into a store
magically everything's there on the
store shelf
but
you know when you when you think about
what it takes
to
to take these items and get them into
the store or get them to your home
there's a behemoth effort at the back
end
a buzzing
sort of a you know complex network of
activity
that needs to be coordinated to take
say an individual item if you take
almond breeze over there
the almond breeze got manufactured
somewhere you know your almond milk your
15 different types of milk and cream and
butter and all of that they all got
manufactured in different places
and so when we think about
logistics the fundamental challenge over
there is to take uniform sources of
physical things
and mix and match them into the right
unit of combination that it could be
delivered to an end point right this
mixing and matching at a physical level
is is very difficult very complicated
and quite expensive
all of that matters when it comes to
making sure that we can buy our goods
out in the real world or we can receive
goods in our house it's too expensive
we get inflation which we've been
watching in the economy it's not that
great the coronavirus pandemic came in
pushed the system to the limit almost
broke it in some cases did break it it's
been recovering
we're seeing the consequences now
at this particular point of time there's
a huge opportunity
to go out
safely
effectively
do
a big chunk of work that is required for
the day-to-day functioning of our
society and do it in a manner that
constructively adds value
so that's what we're focused on
um
let's add a little bit of additional
context here so if we take a news flash
over the past year or so
there's been a pretty intense labor
shortage
so what does this mean
this means that there used to be a bunch
of people
who were doing a variety of different
tasks
and uh the coronavirus pandemic hit they
went out of the workforce a lot of them
thought about life and there's this
interesting phenomena called the great
resignation that's been ongoing where
while you're in the rut you're doing
something it's pretty cool you don't
think about it you wake up in the
morning you go do something now you've
been out of this rut for about a year or
two you rethink life and you decide you
know what that task is something i
should have never been doing i don't
want to do it and i will not go back to
doing it
when you have a situation like that
you you end up in in a situation where
the job still needs to be done but
there's nobody waiting to do it
there's a constructive opportunity for
robotics to enter our society where we
can take automation in get the job done
keep our stores functioning keep our
homes functioning keep food on our plate
keep shampoo in our bathroom and all of
the cool stuff that we expect in a
modern society and do it in a manner
where the need is not necessarily
disruptive it's very important for
robotics and automation and any
technical change to be productive
without being disruptive i know if you
folks will go out and start a plan you
know there's like conferences called
like tech disrupt
and so all of that sounds really cool
but at the end of the day you're gonna
be interacting with uh people you're
gonna impact lives it's important for us
to do that in a respectful healthy and
constructive manner so for us there's an
opportunity right now to
change the status quo
to go out and take robots into
production doing a wide variety of
things that are traditionally pretty
hard to do traditionally very labor
intensive and for us to do it in a
manner where we constructively add value
and we feel really good about it
so
that's a bit of a
spiel from uh from me and uh
you know just wanted to hand it over to
a few other folks from dexterity we've
been working on some exciting challenges
in particular in the package baked goods
industry the packaged food industry and
through the pandemic we were actually in
production
with
all sorts of
robots that were picking and shipping
bread buns cakes we've been in
production with robots that uh pick and
sort parcels those two were things that
were stretched to the max you know the
pandemic head store shelves ran empty
there was no bread there was uh you know
people ordering everything online and
the parcel system also got stretched to
its limit
and so
there's some exciting uh progress that
we'd be happy to share um but more
importantly i think there's a lot of
open problems that have confronted us as
we've taken ideas that were theoretical
that were decades in the making in the
lab we took them out into the real world
unwrapped layers of the onion and we
found
extremely difficult problems continue to
persist and so we'd love to expose you
all to another round of extremely
difficult problems that for us emerged
after we peeled the first couple layers
of the onion with what we already knew
it's super exciting it's a time of
transformation i think it's a time of
global change and i would encourage you
all
to come join us or do something of your
own accord but uh the time to go for
robotics is about now and let's take
this opportunity to do something really
cool
handing it over
to my colleague robertson
thanks amir so my name is robert i'm one
of the founding engineers at dexterity
um also one of the stanford alum uh
from uh
osama's robotics lab i'm gonna talk a
little bit about why
logistics is quite challenging for
robots and how's it different than
robotics used in the past and one of the
main things is
every task that we do with robotics in
logistics is going to be different right
we
have
novel subtasks per action for pretty
much everything that we that we do with
the robot as you can see from this video
whether it's handling a new object
whether it's handling an object that
can't be handled by other upstream uh
automation you're going to be receiving
new things or
different things almost every single
time
when working in production and so this
is greatly different from manufacturing
or other applications robotics when
you have a very clear understanding of
what your robot is going to do
and this really flips the problem right
it makes it
previously you could verify that your
solution always works and now you have
to in real time compute a solution for
every new thing
secondly
the environment that we want to put
ourselves into for logistics is going to
be unstructured these are environments
that
were previously very human friendly and
there was no surrounding automation or
anything that makes it easy for robots
to work in and to make it into an
environment that robots
can be easily operated in is is actually
quite difficult and potentially
unachievable in
environments where you're handling tons
of packages or handling tons of messy
uh objects and so
this makes it that much more difficult
for robots to operate in
and finally
as you probably saw in the video
we saw some various objects that are
quite difficult for robots to operate in
and
as you keep working production you start
realizing there are some crazy things
that show up that robots have to deal
with one time we saw someone ship a box
of soggy cake or
sometimes you're trying to pick up boxes
and the ups label is actually peeling
off and when you try to grip that object
the label peels off and you don't
actually pick up these objects and to
make robots work
and work properly for
logistics applications you really have
to take into account all of the edge
cases and make sure that you can handle
each and every one of them for these
systems to be successful and this is why
logistics is is quite difficult and
basically completely untackled by
robotics especially robots of the past
so what is dexterity doing well we've
built up a platform of technology
of a variety of different forms that
i'll go into today that enables us to
handle and tackle a lot of the logistics
challenges we see today at relative ease
that doesn't mean that we are building
custom things for each and every
individual application we are building
up something that can be shared across
95 of applications and engineers
programmers
software engineers can all use that
platform and easily build and understand
how to
operate robots under logistics
one slide i'd really like to show is we
take a problem first approach
where we are not thinking of a lot of
that technology that we learned in the
past in school and try and apply it to
every problem that we know
we look at the problems and then we take
all of our knowledge all of our
technology and apply them to those
specific problems and if some technology
does not work for that problem or
some technology works better we take
that into account instead of trying to
push
you know something like reinforcement
learning to all the problems or trying
to push control theory to all the
problems right we want to take a
problem-first approach and we've built
our platform with that in regard and
what are the components of this platform
well
we've got a couple key components and i
really want to emphasize sort of the
full stack nature of what we build here
from building custom hardware and custom
grippers and
a lot of custom electronics to really
support the underlying base of our
system building low level control adding
perception and feedback to our control
adding
search planning and learning on top of
that for some more intelligent
interaction or more intelligent motion
planning and then tying it all together
with some vision and understanding of
the world so that we can properly create
these plans
some other components include
tele operation and human interaction
with the robots inevitably the robots
will have to
ask for help or maybe do something that
is
unachievable by the robots or
just uh in a regular workflow of things
need humans to insert or remove things
from the system so there's a degree of
human robot interaction
also involved sometimes even over long
distances or tele-operated
and then finally there's of course tons
and tons of software engineering
required to glue all the pieces together
to understand how you're going to deploy
thousands and thousands of robots into
the field without having a single
engineer watching every single robot
working right
so what is this core platform fuel we
have a couple different products
as you can see here the core platform
really is able to work on all of these
different products all at once and
we'll see in
depth a little bit one of these
one of these applications includes
parcel induction this is a process of
taking
these parcels and packages that you see
when you're shipping something with ups
fedex usps and whatever and we're taking
these objects and putting them one by
one on a conveyor belt in order to be
sorted later downstream now you see this
is a this is a task that's actually done
by humans and an incredibly constrained
and small environment where there's not
enough space for large automation not
enough space and time for
more simple or more you know hard-coded
automation to work and you need
something that will
fall into place and do the job for you
another
big component or big
big application is
palletizing and de-palletizing and this
this problem is something that jonathan
uh
has been working on for quite a while
it's a problem of taking these boxes
that are of arbitrary shaped in sizes
and creating a palette of them you've
seen palettes before maybe at a store or
at uh at a warehouse and most of the
time the palettes you see are of the
same size box which makes it fairly easy
to essentially hard code a pattern that
allows you to fill this palette up
stably it can be fork lifted around
it
is highly efficient and doesn't have
many gaps when the boxes come in a
variety shapes and sizes
it makes it extremely difficult to
actually plan out how to put these boxes
in place it's it's like playing chess
but then the moves you have are actually
different every single time
and finally uh one of our big
applications called fulfillment now
normally you might see robots
in industry today pick and placing an
object from a bin to another bin
or vice versa
fulfillment is a problem greater than
that where you are actually tasked to
build an order
where you have type a object 100 of them
type b object 500 type c object 300 them
and you have
88 orders that you have to fill 2 of a 3
of b five of c right
and
this type of behavior
especially with multiple agents and
multiple robots is actually pretty hard
to coordinate
how to efficiently use your agents to
fulfill this type of ordering and so
this is another level of sequential
decision making that our robots will
need to perform if you want to
effectively and efficiently fulfill
things like orders and
you can check on our website we've been
working on actually fulfilling some of
the toughest orders bread
white bread whole wheat bread whatever
whatever you name it and
these three main products have have
really been
sort of what we see as in the logistics
injury some of the key things that
warehousing and logistics actually works
on and actually needs
and we've been tackling that for the
last four years
so one question i wanted to answer for
folks is
why is logistics and robotics
why now right
and
in my opinion it's it's a couple
different things i think imaging
technology from the past
10 20 years
has not been great but these days from
using real senses from using connects
from using other lidar and other imaging
technology we've seen a great
improvement in the ability to understand
the world understand depth understand
color
and on top of that we've been able to
really commoditize
segmentation and other learning
algorithms to understand those images
from
2012 when
alexnet came to
today you can open up a python notebook
online and probably run a segmentation
engine in like
12 minutes versus back then i mean took
a whole phd in eight years probably
right
robotics hardware and compute today has
also been greatly advancing
compute finally has allowed us to run
some of these modern methods in control
that maybe you guys have been studying
or researching
uh rt algorithms and whatnot we'll talk
a little bit about in the in the later
slides
all this together has really enabled us
to piece together all the different
components to make logistics
possible
to be achieved with robotics today
so we're going to talk about a couple of
key components at dexterity uh in this
talk we'll talk a little bit about
imaging and perception and a little bit
about control so we'll talk about
imaging first
so what are we doing with imaging right
we need to understand where the objects
are what the objects are in the
workspace we work in and we need to
understand how the robot can grasp or
manipulate these objects right
sometimes we even need to understand if
humans are operating within our
environment what are they doing and how
do we
operate after a human has done something
to our environment
there's a lot of different things that
robots need to know as you probably
understand yourselves about the
environment and about perceiving
obstacles or perceiving
other things that will influence the
robot's motion planning decision making
and whatnot and
our
our imaging systems our perception
systems are going to have to provide the
information for our robots to do this
we'll start with
the actual imaging itself
we generally use you know rgbd sensors
to collect dense colored point clouds
about the environment
we can use things like lidar and other
things but you know we found things like
stereo time-of-flight structured light
to be quite useful for us
and that allows us to see and understand
exactly how the environment is shaped
and what colors they are and we can
segment out understand individual
objects create more rich data from this
rgb data
you'll see also that
certain sensors today also pose some
challenges when you're
hitting objects like
plastic bottles or glass or other
transparent things the results of these
sensors might not be very great and you
might see things that are supposed to be
right angles but they are not and you'll
see
interpolation error or
other types of estimation error and
this is something that we have to deal
with and understand right we have to
understand how this error will affect
our estimation and then
go ahead and try to filter or deal with
that so that we can
better pick or better understand the
collisions between objects
we've also noticed that in a logistics
environment things
are going to be changing a lot and
sometimes you'll see nice bright
environments like this where everything
can be seen maybe sometimes you'll see
really dark environments where almost
nothing can be seen
and
this also poses a challenge on both the
imaging and the processing front
furthermore
you might also encounter other
automation like
scanners
safety systems that
might affect your imaging and we also
have to understand how to deal with
those
other effects with our cameras or with
our processing systems
and
that's just a little bit of insight into
sort of the real world examples of how
imaging and how perception can
can be very difficult in a logistics
environment
i'll just add a quick aside here where
even once you
do image or
perceive the environment there is
there's a there's a problem of
transmitting that signal to
transmitting that signal to our
computers or to our servers for
better computation and
one of the key problems that we've
actually encountered is
do we use usb do we use ethernet do we
compute things on the edge and these all
offer different trade-offs in terms of
price performance and reliability this
is something to think of as engineers
as we continue building this
finally we move on to the processing
component
we want to take the perceived images and
our and and depth images and actually
think about how to
analyze or segment out the components in
the real world in this case
we do a lot of object segmentation we
understand what individual objects are
we can de-project them into
three-dimensional pieces and then try to
understand how best to grasp or how best
to manipulate each of these independent
pieces
you'll see we want to understand this on
different levels either it's on a per
object level either it's on a container
level you know when we see trays or
boxes and then from there we will then
process out information like how to
grasp this thing with one robot maybe
how to grasp this thing with two robots
or beyond
and the difficulty here lies that the
amount of diversity in the object space
is extremely large let's let's look at
bread for example i think we've seen
thousands and thousands of types of
bread in the world and you are basically
expected to operate on
all of these products i mean if you put
a human in this type of process
you and i can tell whether something is
a bread something is a pita something is
a box of cake very very easily and you
might think a computer should be able to
generalize that as well and again with
modern methods in
cnns and with segmentation engines this
is basically feasible now and
this just poses a data and
processing problem but
again one of these tough challenges in
logistics another tough challenge is
manufacturers or other companies will
want to change the way that they display
their product change the labeling add
your favorite frozen character
after the holiday season and your system
will have to deal and adapt to that in
real time
the same goes for packages and parcels
i think we've seen people ship seven
jeans in a grocery bag once and you're
gonna have to hand not only segment that
object but handle it as well
and the parcel industry really just
completely explodes in sort of diversity
of the type of objects you're going to
have to handle and
the problem is
you're not going to be able to
categorize every type of object you have
to create the right abstractions in the
right categorizations from a robotics
perspective so that you know how to
handle each and every type of object
maybe you want to split them out into
boxes flat mailers bubble mailers and
try to categorize your objects based on
that so you can create the right
algorithms to handle each and every type
of object
so just a little bit of insight into the
type of type of different things we have
sometimes you'll just end up with a huge
pile of
very similarly
shaped and colored objects and that's
extremely extremely difficult for
computers to handle right
the the texture
difference is very minimal and you'll
really have to fuse together information
from death from rgb and maybe even
future
future perception methods like material
deciphering imaging like like ir or
ultraviolet to be able to detect between
these different objects
what we've done
is created a custom set of grippers and
other hardware to be able to handle each
and every type of object ourselves and
this is
i think
quite interest interesting in that
it's not just about
understanding what objects we're
manipulating understand the
understanding the individual types of
objects but also
sort of reverse optimizing that all the
way down to robot design and robot
hardware design and that's i feel like a
super important piece of
doing modern robotics is to start
building the hardware to support the
control to support the perception
instead of relying on basic hardware to
do all of that stuff
finally one last tidbit is we're also
using perception to understand human
actions as you can see here
these these trays are actually inserted
into our system by a human and
they can actually be
inserted one way or the or the other way
see one side has a window and one side
doesn't so we're using perception
systems to understand how a human
inserts something into the system and
how we might change our control and
change our planning to
adapt to that
so in that sense you know
we have a very nice problem here where
our robots are in production we
run tons and tons of operations on daily
products and we can easily see and
capture data from that environment
hundreds of thousands of images and we
can create this virtuous cycle of
machine learning of
detection of these objects and
continuously improve our systems and so
this
this creates a nice opportunity to do
some interesting
unsupervised learning or
continuous improvement for our robots
and
that's really it on our perception layer
moving on a little bit to controls and
planning
so we've we've been working with control
controlling robots for a very long time
and
control of robots i think is is critical
for dealing with logistics you're doing
a lot of manipulation with the
environment you're performing hard and
soft contact you might have multi-degree
of freedom robots you might have robots
working together
and
understanding and doing a really solid
control
uh layer uh for for robotics is i think
critical for the logistics industry so
what do we do
one of the key things is
the environments are dynamic things are
constantly changing there might be
disturbances
there might be packages falling into
your view and you have to adapt to that
right and we want to create a control
system that can
move extremely fast to do tasks that are
on par with the way that humans do it
but we also want to change on the fly
and comply with the environment
unlike robotics of the past where
they're very very stiff had extremely
high gains and when something about the
environment changed the robot would
crash
and an engineer or someone would have to
come and try to fix it our robots have
to work all the time with these changing
environments
another thing is we want to combine in
perception and perception might include
visual and might include force
perception or touch based perception and
you can see here we're handling some
extremely gentle product
with
a very powerful industrial robot and
that could easily crush or destroy
anything but you once you combine in
some perception
some force sensing your you might be
able to handle objects of all sorts and
this is again necessary for
making sure your package arrives at your
door without it breaking right
and finally we want to create a system
that is really open to everyone to use
and we want to create behaviors like
this where you can create some really
interesting behaviors for robots where
you can
you know
ensure suction on these very difficult
soft body objects and you want to do
this relatively quickly in a week in two
weeks you don't want to spend a really
long time designing optimization
functions or constraints to be able to
do this
and this is an interesting requirement
that
i guess rarely is is talked about
because engineering velocity is not
really a research topic but i think when
you build systems that can support
really strong and fast engineering
velocity it improves the ability for us
to iterate on robot
motions and other other tasks very
easily
so i'll talk a little bit about how we
break down our control
we start with a really rigorous whole
body control method where
with one two or multiple robots we can
define a hybrid force and motion control
task
this allows us to easily
control
specific tasks in the robot maybe an end
effector position task maybe orientation
task maybe a
conditioning task to
you know put your robot in a better
posture
on top of that we'll put on trajectory
tracking and different closed loop
behavior that allows us to use that
whole body control from before and track
a plan trajectory later and sometimes
you're going to be deviating from that
trajectory sometimes you're going to
want to inject in perception to
change the way that
you work on that nominal trajectory
and this might be done originally with
heuristics then we might add some mpc or
different things on it so that we can
blend between trajectories or
adapt to a changing environment in real
time
and
we want to also optimize and smooth the
trajectories a little bit given
given initial planning
finally
i think one key component is trajectory
generation in and of itself
trajectory generation uh traditionally
you might think rrts or
other other planning methods
don't really take into account the
previous layers and if we wanted to plan
in joint space that becomes infeasible
so how do we inject in some of the lower
layer constraints or ideals
so that we can
properly plan and adapt for for the
environment
one thing that i'd like to touch upon
here is this this term sc3 plus
so you might plan in
cartesian and orientation space
but what if your robot had more joints
or more ability to move i mean when
you're playing tennis uh you're not just
standing still and moving your arm right
you're moving your head your legs around
you're moving your body around to better
condition yourself and so the planning
should really happen across this entire
stack where
you're thinking about how best to
condition your robot for maximum
utilization maximum speed while also
planning the trajectory in and of itself
so that's why what i call sort of sc3
plus and then finally with all these
layers together you can start building
behaviors on top of this robot
there's one more layer that i like to
tell you about which is sequential
decision problems
where
yes all those planning all of that
control is very nice but your robot
still has to do something maybe
palletize maybe
sequence the
objects we're placing on a belt and
sometimes these problems are
the actions that these problems have are
sometimes going to be feasible or
sometimes infeasible based on the
control think about palletizing for
example if we
build a wall in front of us and try to
reach over it your robot arm is going to
hit this wall
so we need to inject in some amount of
heuristics or other planning or other
learning about our sequential decision
making to make it feasible for lower
levels to execute that
decision making problem and
this is a little bit difficult because
you know you can't optimize the entire
problem all the way through you can't
plan a robot trajectory every time you
want to
search for a better location for a box
and this makes it quite difficult to
actually optimize the this type of
problem
the same goes for our scheduling
problems when we're talking about
fulfillment our robots have to figure
out in a multi-aging capacity how best
to
move
objects around and
whether it's in singles or in groups
with the with accounting for the fact
that robot arms are still the ones that
are doing it these objects are not
teleporting
so i'll hand it over to canal a little
bit to dive a bit into motion planning
that's what he's been working on a lot
hey everyone i'm canal uh it's a
graduate here like what six months ago
so it's kind of surreal to be on this
side of the stage
so i'm gonna talk a little about motion
planning today
so if you think about motion planning
it's relatively
straightforward objective
we have some box bread box whatever
thing and we want to move it from a to b
and we don't want to have any collisions
right
relatively simple premise and
if you look at this video
we the usage for this is sort of
we want to work we want this to work for
all sort of planning tasks
and we want this to be a little bit
customizable so if you saw the motions
here
replay the video
there's sort of different tasks going on
here the robot wants to pick up an
individual object a whole tray
it wants to move this um
this red thing we call the dolly so sort
of a different motion there
and it also wants to move the entire
stack of bread closer to itself so it
can reach for it
so how do you sort of build a system
that can sort of do all of these tasks
within sort of the same framework
and you don't necessarily want one
method in your framework if one type of
motion fails you want to fall back you
will eventually want to complete the
motion so you don't have to get some
human operator to come help
and today i'm going to be primarily
speaking about geometric path planning
so what that means is we'll just modify
the speed profile later so we're mostly
interested in some curve in space p of s
and we'll deal with the speed s of t
later
and the idea is that we're going to let
control handle the trajectory right now
we want to focus on the actual geometric
path
so we've been doing motion planning for
a while and specifically in the realm of
sampling based motion planning there are
methods that you might be familiar with
are teit fmt
and you might be thinking well you know
we've had these for
ten to five years this should be great
if i just plug in lmpl
hit go i should get a path
that's what i thought but the answer is
kind of no
uh you can give these methods
seconds tens of seconds minutes
and sometimes they'll fail for even
simple pads like this
and some of the underlying issues that
is that if we try to plan in joint space
well it becomes a little difficult we
have limited we want to have limited
planning time we have maybe 100
milliseconds
to do this motion
but how do we enforce sort of the world
bounce right so the
normal way people do this is you sample
some joint space and joint configuration
you check collision and if that results
in collision you do rejection sampling
rejection sampling works really well
if the area you're sampling is
relatively big to what you care about
right if you're going to redirect
rejection sampling
60 70 of your points it's not very
useful as a method
you can come in and try to find a path
in just se3
and again we have limited planning time
these spaces are big
and the issue here is that we have many
wasted samples you might imagine if
you're picking up you know an object
from here to here there's no real sense
in me sampling orientations that are
like sort of wacky pointing upwards
right we kind of want to like
have orientations that make sense maybe
a little bit
in plane out of plane but not completely
upside down that would just be silly
and that kind of comes into this idea of
position-based orientation sampling
where really what we're doing at motion
planning is we have
some not only a goal point a goal start
state and um
we also have a goal orientation
so the idea here is that we can like
sample points we also want to sample
their orientation so fully sampling this
state here
and the way we do this if we sample
cartesian
points sort of normally how you would
imagine you have some bounding box you
sample from there uniform gaussian
distribution
and the idea is then you can use this to
get sort of the approximate distance of
that position to the start and end and
you can use this for some sort of
interpolation strategy
right so you can imagine if i have two
orientations i can linearly interpolate
between them
over some basis or their angle
quaternions whatever you want
or you can get a little bit fancy with
your interpolation strategies and you
can use things like sigmoids and
sigmoids are nice because what they let
you do is they let you do most of the
orientation in the middle
and if you imagine for things like
palletization or bread where the final
and initial orientation is really really
relatively constrained right
you want to pick them up straight you
want to drop them in straight so if you
need to rotate them you want to do most
of that sort of in the middle
so if you look at this video
so you'll see that we're gonna pick up
the box we're gonna do most of the
orientation sort of in the first 30 to
60 percent
and then towards the end we've sort of
settled on the final rotation
and if you look really closely at this
box you might be wondering while the box
is symmetric why are we even rotating it
right
there's no real need for me to do that
maneuver i can sample in r3 it'll be
great
and unfortunately we're not necessarily
doing these motions in a vacuum right
we're doing them between
between successive pick and places and
we have all of these cables and whatnot
attached to the robot itself
we need to be cognizant about
not over rotating the gripper if we
can't we can't just rotate completely
continuously in one direction it'll get
tangled air pipes will break everyone's
sad you call the mech team they're mad
at you you don't want to do that
so we want to do is we want to take
these ideas and somehow put them into
the motion planner this kind of calls
back to this se3 plus idea we're not
necessarily just playing in one specific
space we have other constraints and we
need
ways to deal with those constraints and
sort of the same con continuity
so how does this position based
orientation sounding work well yeah the
idea here is relatively simple we can
use an axis angle method to do this
so we have some start orientation s some
goal orientation g we can get the
relative orientation between them
if you're not familiar with quaternions
you can think about these as rotation
matrices the math is more or less the
same
we can find the angle and axis of this
rotation so every three dimension
rotation has a principal axis there's a
rotation about and some angle that
rotates through
and we can create some sort of sampling
method about this so we can add a little
bit of noise to this axis and we can add
a little bit of noise to angle itself so
we return a sampled point
based on some interpolation strategy
and this is really nice because it lets
us
sort of bias the orientation towards
some sort of nominal path right
we have some path that we think is
relatively straightforward but we still
want this like nice
sampling based nature about this point
to help us sort of wiggle out of tight
situations
and this dramatically can reduce the
time take time needed to find these
paths so in this example here
um
we have some
trajectory that we're trying to plan
some orientation we're sweeping through
this is sort of the graph of the angle
about this principal axis i didn't want
to plot too many things here
the idea here is that we can basically
follow whatever nominal path we want and
add a little bit of noise to help us
wiggle out of these sort of tight corner
situations to create these sort of
collision tree collision free
trajectories
um quite quickly
another method we have is this
cone-based method
i don't have fancy names for these quite
yet
so the idea here is that
we can define a per axis distribution
so if you think about euler angles you
can think about a pure axis distribution
here
and the idea is to simply just
parameterize the variance so you have
very little variance the beginning and
ends of these trajectories
and most of your orientation is
happening in the middle or whatever
according to whatever
parametrized variances you have
so you'll see at the ends there's no
orientation
motion here and then as we get towards
the middle of this trajectory there's a
lot more
um
a lot more sampled points
and this helps with more exploration in
the middle that's normally where you
have the most free space to move around
without collisions and again all these
points are being collision checked but
there's still some level of rejection
sampling happen but at a much much lower
rate
and this is really helpful for what we
call top-down situations which is what
you've seen with the palletization robot
which is what you've seen with the bread
robot
is a lot of these
um actions have very little world pitch
and roll
so if you're picking up a box and you're
going to place it there's no real reason
for you to tilt it a whole bunch out of
plane you're going to mostly just want
to rotate them
so the underlying idea is to just bias
your sample towards rotations that make
sense for the actual task at hand
so an example of this is our
authorization robot and if you can look
closely
there's a little bit of pitch and roll
happening but for the most part
most of the orientation that's happening
is in the world the offering
and this lets us dramatically just two
dimensions you're basically getting rid
of which is incredibly helpful for
solving these problems in
tens and hopefully maybe even ones of
milliseconds and what does this finally
relate to well this relates to
boxes right we're moving boxes we've
been looking at boxes since we were like
two wire boxes so hard
well unfortunately
oh
this image doesn't show up
um there's a lot of boxes just like are
completely unreliable
there's tape in the way there's holes
there's a hole in the box you try to
apply suction it's not going to work
these sorts of things
and you want to develop motion planning
and control and grasping techniques that
can handle these sort of like edge cases
the long tail of these boxes
and again you're not
only operating on these like weird boxes
in a vacuum right they're interacting
with each other you get a whole bunch
off
some pallet or something and then you
start stacking them and then these sort
of like errors keep adding up and you
get like wacky things like this right
and it's not just these deformed boxes
there's also people ship
crazy things mattresses kayaks like
imagine you're the guy who has to put
the kayak in like a pallet or truck
right that's like really really
difficult
so
how do you come up with a robotic system
using all of our representations of
geometry and data
to successfully complete these tasks in
a reasonable amount of time with having
to call a human operator every five
minutes
thanks for that quick quick uh intro on
our motion planning so one thing i just
want to stress is
we really take this full stack
full stack approach to robotics right
we know that
robots working in the logistics world is
going to be a really tough problem given
the changing environment giving the
constantly changing tasks and different
things that are thrown at us and
just trying to solve it in certain
layers and perception or certain layers
and control or certain layers of motion
planning is is not going to cut it and
you might i'm not going to say it's
impossible but you might spend 20 years
doing one thing
versus
a month changing your gripper
and so
i think to reduce the friction in
providing
robots that work for our logistics
customers it's extremely important to
try to optimize at whatever layer on the
stack as needed to solve these types of
problems
these types of problems we need to
provide a sort of turnkey solution for
our customers right and
if you provide a robot that just does
one thing
and
people keep
needing to feed it or um
it's uh
it can only pick and place one thing but
it doesn't fulfill an order this doesn't
really solve the problem and you need to
provide this whole entire solution the
peripherals the safety the perception
all of it combined in order to actually
make a difference in the logistics world
or in any world with robotics to be
honest
and i think this makes
this makes tackling this problem
actually extremely difficult that's why
at dexterity we've really employed a
wide range of people from motion
planning and trajectory optimization
experts sequential decision making
experts mechanical engineering experts
design experts every everyone from every
field to be able to tackle this entire
problem to actually make a difference to
give robotics the justice it really
deserves after 20 to 30 years of
stagnation and manufacturing and take it
into the real world
so like i said it doesn't just end at
robotics
things like software engineering
motor design
game playing
and variety of different types of fields
all really play together to enable
robots and massively fleet deployed
robots out in the field to work
effectively
so dexterity is taking this full stack
approach to robotics and
hopefully you guys understand why we're
doing that and maybe be able to make a
difference as well
thanks everyone
so i'm just going to put up some names
of these people if you want to contact
them um for some information
myself i work primarily on whole body
control quinoa works on motion planning
jonathan works on sequential decision
making problems like the palletizing or
scheduling problems uh andrew bailard
works on trajectory optimization and
we've got lynn who's also
a stanford alum alumni here today she
works a lot on computer vision
folks uh samir again uh just wanted to
say thank you very much for listening in
our goal in this uh presentation was to
give a high level overview of some of
the things that are very difficult in
logistics a quick snippet of a few
different things that we've been doing
in particular handling boxes packages
package baked goods like bread
a bit of a deep dive into the nuances of
a particular problem which we saw uh is
something as simple as picking up a box
and putting it on a pallet is actually
far more complex than we can imagine
i think the takeaway message that i
would love for you folks to take
from this stock is that robotics has as
you know it's an onion there's many
layers
you might think you have an optimal sort
of idea or a framework to solve all of
robotics
um
that's great you put into production you
go to 95 percent what you have to do is
you have to rescale your 95 back to five
and you take that remaining five and
that's your new 95
so you go there again and then you do it
again you do it again and again and
again and again you have to do that many
many many times before you actually end
up at
something that you can say works in the
real world it's extremely hard
there is no
shortage of
very very difficult theoretical
engineering pragmatic
challenges that you'll face it's an
exciting field for people to come in and
do work i think for the next 10 or 20
years we'll be working at the cutting
edge no matter where you're working on
robotics so i would strongly encourage
you to come
join us or you know do something in
robotics yourself we are super excited
about robotics and
as you can see it's a bit of a stanford
team here you know we have robert kunal
uh me andrew jonathan and we have hamia
huang who is now an investor client
perkins also invested in dexterity
standard phd as well so
all the best good luck and thank you for
your attention
[Applause]
you